well I'm joined Now by Yuval Noah Harari
yal thank you very much indeed for
joining me I wanted to start on a
personal note I understand that you had
family members uh at the kabut when
these Horrors were unfurling on October
the 7th uh how are they and tell me
about what they
experien well my my aunt and uncle live
in kibuts B which is one of the
communities that was attacked and
occupied by the Hamas terrorists uh my
aunt and Uncle who he's 100 years old
and my aunt is 90 years old they hid in
their house as terrorists went
systematically from house to house in
their kibuts and tortured and executed
and murdered people their neighbors and
friends in the most horrific ways uh
they somehow survived and they and tens
of thousands of other Israelis from the
border region are now refugees is inside
in in
Israel I mean a horrific experience as
so many experienced on that day I've
been debating on this show ever since
about what constitutes a proportional
response by Israel I'm sure that you've
wrestled with that too what have you
concluded what is the correct response
here for Israel to retaliate or exact
revenge or just to defend themselves
however you want to categorize it what
is the best way for isra to do
this I think we should avoid thinking in
terms of Revenge as a historian I know
that um the curse of History the worst
thing about history is that people try
to correct the past people try to save
the past and this is impossible you
cannot go back to the past and and uh
save the people there or to prevent the
past injuries we need to look to the
Future and in the present circumstances
this means that on the one hand Israel
must defend its uh citizens and must
disarm Hamas and end the Hamas control
of the Gaza Strip not just so that my
family and tens of thousands of other
Israelis could go back to living next to
the Gaza Strip but also Hamas is
intentionally destroying any chance for
for future peace you know the reason
this attack was launched now the reason
for the timing of the attack was that
Israel was very close to signing a
historical peace treaty with Saudi
Arabia uh which was supposed not just to
normalize relations between Israel and
the Arab world but also to restart the
Israeli Palestinian peace process and to
include concessions that will alleviate
the suffering of millions of
Palestinians in the occupied territories
and the aim of Hamas was to foil this
peace treaty and to destroy any chance
for peace in the future as well by
committing horrible
atrocities uh that will seow seeds of
hatred in the minds of millions of
people so even those interested in peace
must be in favor of disarming Hamas at
the same time Israel should remain
committed to international law and to
the Future chances for peace there will
not be h a peace just by disarming Kamas
we also need to give a future to the
Palestinians in the G strep and in the
West Bank so that they can live
dignified lives in their Homeland but
how do you dismantle or eradicate Hamas
given they're a terror group that live
amongst the civilian population we know
this if and if you need the population
to come with you on this process of
removing Hamas surely what is going on
at the moment is having the opposite
effect if thousands and thousands of
Palestinian civilians who had nothing to
do with it are being slaughtered um on a
daily basis it seems and if that
escalates through a ground Invasion then
surely it will have the opposite effect
won't it I mean you may well end up
dismantling a lot of Hamas terrorists
but if you also kill tens maybe hundreds
of thousands of civilians you are surely
going to alienate those people from
wanting any form of deal with anybody
after
this absolutely and this is why Israel
should be very careful about the way it
operates uh Israel is not a terrorist
organization like Hamas it is not aiming
to kill as many civilians as
possible uh it is very difficult of
course to fight a terrorist organization
which is hiding inside a civilian
population ideally uh there should be a
way for for civilians to move out of the
combat zones uh Egypt that shares a
border with the Gaza Strip uh should be
willing to accept Palestinian civilians
for the duration of of the war in order
to protect them I would say that even
Israel should explore the possibility of
receiving at least women and children
from the Gaza Strip into Israeli
territory you know maybe allow the Red
Cross or some other international
organization to build temporary safe
havens for Gaz and civilians on Israeli
soil for the duration of the conflict
again I don't know if this is feasible I
don't know exactly uh uh this is not my
expertise but
certainly um if Israel wins the war
against Hamas without providing for an
alternative future for the Palestinian
civilian population we will only get
something even worse than Kamas a few
years down the line you're a historian
as you said earlier this has been going
on now for over 70 years this conflict
yeah it flares up um every few years it
seems with some new form of of hideous
Warfare uh when you chart back to the
very start of all this which many people
are trying to do to try to explain how
we've reached this place was the big
mistake in the first place the
displacement of several hundred thousand
Palestinians
mhm well you know it's very difficult in
history to to there is always something
that happened previously you know people
think about history as a chain of events
but there is always a link before the
first link and um even more importantly
it's not a chain it's a system of roots
every event in history usually has have
a lot of different contributing effects
and you know people for instance talk a
lot these days and for many years and
for good reasons about the suffering of
hundreds of thousands of Palestinians
who lost their homes in 1948 few people
know that as a result of the 1948 War
also hundreds of thousands of Jews lost
their homes in retaliation for the War
uh Jewish communities all over the
Middle East in Arab countries in Egypt
in Iraq in Yemen in Syria who lived
there for hundreds sometimes thousands
of years and had nothing to do with the
war they were driven out hundreds of
thousands of Jews the
largest group of people now living in
Israel are Jews that were expelled as
refugees as a result of the 1948 War now
does this justify what happened to the
Palestinian Ians know does this justify
the Israeli occupation and the
mistreatment of Palestinians there
absolutely not then we shouldn't use
historical injuries to justify more
injuries but the thing is that it's very
difficult to understand the root causes
of histor of complex historical
conflicts and the key message should be
don't try to go back to the past and
change it this is
impossible focus on the Future Past
injuries should be healed and not used
as an excuse to inflict more injuries
we've been trying this way of inflicting
more and more injuries for Generations
we have to stop at a certain point and
again the key idea is if you have to
choose between Justice and peace choose
peace every peace treaty in the history
of the world
was based on compromise no we need some
level of justice of course but there is
never a possibility of absolute Justice
if you pursue absolute Justice you will
only perpetuate War indefinitely most
people believe there can be no peace
deal with Hamas given the appalling
Terror attacks of October the 7th but
many people also feel including many
Israelis I've talked to believe there
can't be any peace Steel as long as BB
Netanyahu remains in charge of Israel uh
do you share that view do you think that
uh that on well for many reasons one his
attack earlier in the year on the
Judiciary on the Integrity of the
Supreme Court the social unrest that
cause the division in Israel perhaps
even distracted his defense and
intelligence uh people away from uh from
what they should have been doing which
may have contributed to the way Hamas
was able to execute this attack uh for
all these reasons
do you think it would be prudent for
Israel to find new
leadership absolutely I mean Neto has
been ruling Israel for most of the last
14 years he has based his political
career on dividing the nation against
itself on pointing a finger at
particular sections of Israeli society
and calling them
traitors um he has weakened any state
institution including the security
forces that might challenge or limit his
authority as he recently tried to do to
the courts and especially to the Supreme
Court um and he attacked the serving
Elites of the country again calling them
deep State traitors and and so forth the
people who were foremost in serving the
country in the security forces in the
courts elsewhere were labeled as as as
traitors the very word elite became a
kind of word as if it's there is
something wrong in wanting to be
foremost in in in service to the state
and this is the deep cause of the
dysfunction of many governmental systems
not only on the day of the attack but in
in ever since then
ideally uh if netan really cared about
the state of Israel he should have just
taken responsibility for the disaster
and resigned and allow the Israeli
people to come together at this very
difficult time alternatively if he
thinks he's the only one that can manage
this H H crisis then he should have said
okay I'm calling an election in six
months I'm not running myself to the
elections so nobody can suspect that I'm
managing this war in a particular way
for my personal interest I'm stepping
down I'm just staying for uh until the
election and then I will resign and and
and take responsibility for what has
happened he's not doing that no he he
won't even actually apologize for the
failings of October the 7th on his part
absolutely he's his kind of propaganda
machine is constantly blaming everybody
else the security forces the
intelligence the protest movement
everybody but himself he was perfectly
okay for for for for all all these
years um again I I I at the present
moment Israel is have so many problems
ahead of us but it would have made
Israel Israel's position much stronger
if at the present moment we had a
different more trustworthy more
responsible leadership um yal I want to
try and end if I can on some kind of
positive note again with your historian
haton what is the best case scenario for
how this now all plays out out which
could potentially lead to some form of
Peace in in the region for a conflict
that's gone on for over seven decades
now yeah ideally um we should be able to
disarm Hamas and to go back to the Saudi
deal uh to restart the peace process
from a a a better position of es with a
different Israeli leadership which
appreciates the fact that are giving the
Palestinians hope for the future and
enabling the Palestinians to live
dignified lives and to uh have their own
state in their Homeland is in Israel's
best interest it's not a concession we
are making for others this is something
for our future as well whether this is
possible or not I don't know but what I
do know from history is that at at at
terrible time like this any thought of
future peace and Reconciliation seems
utterly impossible but you know many
people are comparing the atrocities
committed by Hamas to some of the
atrocities in the
Holocaust and seven or eight decades
after the Holocaust now Jews and Germans
are very good friends yes so if this is
possible I think even Israelis and
Palestinians can eventually reconcile
and be friends yeah and I remember the
the Northern Ireland uh conflict and I
remember people thinking that was
completely intractable and there could
never be peace with the the bombing
campaign by the IRA and so on for
decades and there was peace and in the
end it came down to good to good
leadership and hard work and compromise
on both sides as you say history tells
you you have to you have to give way
everybody has to um you can't win
everything you want to get peace uh y
thank you very much indeed for joining
me I appreciate it thank you